let's talk about the Derby to start with
it's this weekend A lot of people very
much looking forward to it do you have
some apprehension yeah of course for
apprehensive given the the public and
clear threats at animal Rising have made
to illegally disrupt that's one of the
reasons we went to the high court to get
an injunction against on Friday which we
were successful in doing
um it's a shame they've decided to have
done this illegal route given the new
animal Rising have been offered and
indeed have we're very pleased they've
taken up
um the possibility of um and the and
indeed a place after Epsom race course
to protest legally which we are fully
supportive of so there's always
apprehension especially when you see
stories like they're in the front page
of a national newspaper this morning but
I think for us it's a fantastic event
you know it's a it's a it's a it's an
iconic part of the British racing indeed
sporting calendar
um in one or two Britain's second
biggest spectator sport so we're really
optimistic we've got a fantastic couple
of days ahead of us with with some with
something for everyone what are you
planning to do Claudia
um well we're going to be there because
we care about these horses and we think
it's wrong that they are put in a
position where they are exploded where
they are being whipped where they have
metal pieces put in their mouth that are
uncomfortable to help control them and
when when their lives are at risk we
know horse dies every other day in
British horse racing and so we're going
to be there to try and protect these
horses by doing well well and to put a
spotlight on on our relationship with
them the way we treat animals well we
will be having a demo at the front which
we're very grateful for that space thank
you for that and there are people who
are willing to try and put their bodies
in the line between animals and the
Harm's Way
it will happen a bitter well we've seen
um as I've already mentioned it is legal
to go on the track it is illegal to
disrupt any form of the day run the
Racecourse around the parade ring
um we have a robust
um detailed security plan in place for
just such possibilities
um sorry police are obviously part of
that they've been very helpful to us
um we hope nothing will happen we hope
things will pass off peacefully and um
sorry we prepared to break the law well
ultimately what this falls down to again
is is these animals and and doing what's
right for them and taking responsibility
and so I don't think this is any
different to what most people would do
which is if they see an animal are you
prepare to break the law well would you
smash a window if you saw a dog in a hot
car are you prepared to break the law I
think I'm I'm prepared to do what's
necessary to do what's right by these
animals and try and prevent them from
being harmed does that mean breaking the
law if it means breaking the law we know
that law isn't always equal to morality
and we know that people have had to
break laws throughout history to create
the change that we we need and again
what this is about is protecting these
animals it's about trying to create the
change that we need to see where we
don't see animals as property where we
don't see them as objects for our use
for our entertainment and value them and
care for them as the beings that they
are what do you do well that's for the
police and the courts to decide and the
court says where we will end up because
there is an injunction place they will
be in contempt of court and therefore it
is illegal it will ultimately then beef
as I say for the police and courts to
decide
um we all we can do is plan
um for what may or may not happen and
have every contingency covered but I'd
just like to point pick up on a few
things that Claudia said they're this
sport has never been safer for these
horses we love these equine athletes
these superstars who get fantastic care
behind the scenes 99.8 percent of horses
come back from their races perfectly
safe and sound we've spent us at
industry we've spent 40 million on
welfare over the last 20 years and
actually it's not really about horse
welfare animal rising or factory using
racing which is a huge platform as I say
Britain's second biggest spectator sport
over 100 days of terrestrial TV coverage
our number rising's calls goes Way
Beyond racing and indeed
um Nathan McGovern one of Chloe's
colleagues gave us an interview to Lee
models head as a senior rather at the
racing post this morning in which he
said he's best he said that it's
actually not about Animal Welfare racing
this is about a much wider agenda that
doesn't really allow the Thoroughbred to
exist and doesn't allow people to even
have pets K as well
oh I don't think that's entirely
representative of what we're doing but
did you say that or not and do you agree
um I think we can have positive
relationships with animals I myself well
I myself have a dog and okay Nina and
Kelly and and I love them and they're I
love dogs too yeah and they're a really
important part of of our families and so
I think we can absolutely continue to
have these positive relationships but no
thoroughbreds well I think no
thoroughbreds right would any breeding
industry where we are treating animals
as property where we are often
jeopardizing their welfare for the sake
of of profit yes we need to move away
from that and we need to find ways to
love animals in ways that are in line
with these values of loving the club
risking the welfare of these horses no I
don't believe we are these Porsches are
born and bred to race as you've
correctly pointed out okay
um without racing there is no breeding
without breeding there is no
Thoroughbred I actually spoke to your
colleague Neil Patterson about this a
few weeks ago and animal rising's agenda
would lead to the extinction of the
Thoroughbred so we have taken we yeah
but what what reasonable person wants to
lead to the extinction of a certain
breed of any animal that just doesn't
compute well so what we do is we breed
thousands of these animals for the sake
of using them and I think what's really
sad is that we can't imagine their
existence for any other purpose than for
us using them and I do think we are we
are putting their welfare at risk when
we put them Trace we know that a horse
dice every other race we know that they
are whipped
not every other recipes
come back perfectly safely in a sport
that provides enjoyment to Millions
around the world and employment
it's an industry statistic and what I
would say is that we have so many ways
we can enjoy ourselves that don't
involve an animal being whipped across
the track and I don't think it's an out
their Viewpoint to not want to exploit
animals to not want to bring them
unnecessary suffering and we can have
these things we can have positive
relationships with animals that don't
involve their exploitation response it's
not exploitation at all these animals
love what they do how many died at um at
uh the Grand National there were three
deaths at the Grand National one death
for horses one too many we know that
that's wise a sport with the point is if
those horses hadn't been at the Grand
National they wouldn't have lied yeah
but the chances of the chances of any
animal dying on a race track or at home
with a Chance of flannel dying at home
is much much slower than it is on a
higher I should say than it is on a race
track the fact is they're at the surface
when they're on a race track Lucinda
Russell herself Grand National winning
Trader now a double Grant National
burning trainer said this herself when
the horses are at home it takes any care
they need takes much longer to come and
when they're on a race track but the
Vets are right there much safer on the
track I don't think that's the
to make when these horses continue to
die when we see Hill 16 was the 50 of
to die so far that year uh 20
horses have died in British horse racing
alone in May which is flat racing season
which is said to be the safest and so
when we are putting these animals in
this situation for the sake of our
entertainment when we absolutely don't
need to how can we justify that if we
say we love these horses as we say we do
if we love these horses we want them to
exist we want them to do what they love
doing we want them to race and they race
fantastically and the risk grid the
fatality rate is infinites and below and
getting lower all the time let me me
just go back to the derby before we
finish Claudia if people are running
onto the track when these forces are
racing isn't that putting them in danger
well they're in danger when they're
running if you run in front of them are
you not putting those horses their
welfare the welfare of the jockeys the
welfare of the people there is
absolutely our priority and we would not
run in front of the libraries
um if these horses are spooked then a
question I have is why were fireworks
set off before the Epson Derby last year
the welfare is the priority what we're
doing is to protect them and to protect
them essentially from an industry that
does harm them and does exploit them I
don't agree don't agree they exploit
them at all this is a fantastic industry
that provides entertainment to Millions
employment to thousands and loves the
Thoroughbred and probably looks after us
athletes better than any other sport
excellent discussion guys it's good to
see you both thank you very much thank
you